taylor clark on the bound for the
diamond backstage d-backs four-nothing
winners in game one a pair of seven
inning games tonight
that'll work into the left-field corner
so pilar is gonna have a double
a little bit of a hanger from clark
start a new streak
and this ball lined to center field to
base hit pilar around third he's coming
home and the rockies have a one-nothing
lead
out of the gate
for trevor his 27th rbi that's a good
start
and le castro gets it started the
counter punch is underway a lead-off
single
castro's at second then meters at first
christian
sends a little dying quail out to right
center it drops in la castro had to hold
up and they'll stop him at third hampson
gave chase and almost got there
but the diamondbacks with no outs have
the bases loaded for david peralta up
the middle and throw into center the
castro scores here comes van meter the
throw is offline and it's 2-1
diamondbacks
[Music]
down the line smothered by mcmahon who
makes a terrific play they only get one
walker's home and it's three to one
but ryan mcmahon saved at least one run
right there
vogt reaches out and pokes it into short
left
here comes peralta 4-1 diamondbacks
base it for the castro ahmed is home
here comes steven vogt here's the throw
and he's in there
6-1 diamondbacks la castro's second hit
in the first inning
and the diamondbacks have opened up a
big first inning cushion
mcmahon originally doubled he's now at
third tony walters a walk
ramel tapia a walks pillar doubled his
first time up that ball is tomahawk to
left and it's fair down that left field
line mcmahon has scored
walters has scored and tapia scores and
the rockies are right back in it kevin
pilar's second double of the night
clears the bases and this wasn't a
strike this was like a shoulder high
faster that's all right get on top of it
tomahawk i think is a great description
of what he did all right you got a
prediction for van meter here he's going
to get a base hit to right center on a
hot streak
and meter hits the fly ball deep to
right field sam hilliard backing up at
the wall
it's gone
josh van meter
a three-run homer and it's nine to four
diamondbacks
up the middle and that one sneaks under
the glove of hampson
mathison heads for third
john jay two for three today
the whole time you've got one eye on the
runner from first base it uh yeah it can
fry your brain that pops straight up in
the air look at mathis at home and it's
10 to four
even smith haven smith deep fly ball
right field there it goes
payment smith his first major league
home run
and the diamondbacks have opened up a
big lead in game two against the rocky
man here he goes corey
stay with us corey corey walk toward the
light
[Music]
and corey's got it all right
well he's got 10 strikeouts huey
this year in four and two-thirds that's
the good news
the bad news is he just gave up a home
run which is good news for the rockies
first pitch ryan mcmahon crush didn't
take long yeah that wasn't the original
bad news i was gonna give him it's the
fact that he's walked seven
in four and two thirds
so mack plows one out his eighth of the
year that's good to see
he's got another hit i mean he's found
the barrel four times
and that'll do it diamondbacks take both
games of the doubleheader from colorado
a four-nothing win in game one 11-5 in
game two